SPEAKER: What's up, everyone?
Thanks for checking
out this week
in Cloud, where we serve
you the lowest latency news.
Recently, we announced Cloud
Services Platform in beta
to help you modernize your apps.
This week, we're making
things even easier
with a beta for CSP
config management,
allowing you to create a
consistent configuration
for your Kubernetes resources
in multi-cluster setups.
It even uses the native
Kubernetes format,
such as XAML or JSON, making
it easy to get your existing
definitions applied to
all of your clusters,
as well as integrating with Git
to make continuous integration
simple.
Make a note to check out
CSP config management
as soon as you can.
Between Google Search,
Google Maps, and YouTube,
our products handle huge amounts
of data with high performance.
The technology that
keeps these running
is available to everyone through
Cloud Bigtable, which now lets
you globally distribute data.
Cloud Bigtable is a managed
wide-column NoSQL database
that can scale from
gigabytes to petabytes
while still maintaining high
performance and low latency.
With global replication,
you can create
multiple primary clusters.
So if you're working with
IoT, finance, ad tech,
gaming, or just about
anything else, check it out.
Speaking of huge
amounts of data,
Google Cloud Storage
is a great place
to store unstructured data.
And you can choose
different ways
to store that data,
such as making
sure it's served up
quickly using multi-region
or kept safe using
georedundant ColdLine.
We're excited to share that
ColdLine is now cheaper.
And we have a new
way to protect you
from unpredictable storage
growth, the storage growth
plan.
You can commit to a
fixed amount per month
and not be charged for any
usage over your commitment.
You can then renew
after 12 months,
and your overage is
free if it's within 30%.
This is a great way to
better forecast your costs,
so try out Google
Cloud Storage and see
if you can save some cash.
Now that you can
store all that data,
the next step is
probably analyzing it,
and that means BigQuery.
We've just launched a
new data analysis quest
to help you get up to speed on
using BigQuery to troubleshoot
common SQL issues and to
build your own custom data
visualizations.
Even better, you
can use the code
3g-bigquery-785 to get
the first lab free.
So get started on learning how
to query petabytes and even
start to build machine
learning models.
Get questing.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Have any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.